サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリヨダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日は難しい話にならないようにと努力はします
約束はできませんが 今日のテーマはね
するべきことがわからない
それからそれぞれの役割
責任ということになりますが
結局そのテーマではなくて
別なことを話します これ
この問題 なんで起こるのかというね
そういうところが 仏教は一番この根本的なところがところのことを説明しますから
この派手に見える問題じゃないんですね
お腹が痛いと言ったら
それは何とかではなくて
なんで痛いのかとか 原因を探すんですね
そういうことですから
このどうしても仏教の場合は
人間の問題の一番根本的なところね
基本的なところのを説明して解決策を提案するんですね
それは世の中ね 誰もあんまりやらないことなんですね
仏教は科学的というのはそういうわけで
徹底的に原因を調べてみる
この現象で引っかかることはしません
まず あの  テーマをちょっと置いておいて
こちらに行きましょう
心は乱れる 心は揺れ乱れるものであると説かれています
心の状況は揺れ 揺れ 常に揺れて乱れているものであると
それは心なんですね 揺れること
乱れることは安定しないというのはね
心の本当の姿なんですね
これがお釈迦様の言葉なんですね
パンダナンチャパランチッタン
それで簡単な簡単に気持ちが変わることは
チャパランという言葉で言ってるんですね
なんか人間の気持ちというのはすぐ変わってしまいます
これは普通なんです で
心はもう本当にもうすごい簡単に揺れ動くものであると
まあたとえもありますけどね
例えば枝にある柔らかいね
新しい葉 葉っぱが下から何かゴゴッと煙なんか出してると
もう揺れて揺れてもう揺れまくっちゃって
結局はもう悪くなってしまいますね
燃えてしまいますね  そんなような感じで
その時はこの柔らかい葉っぱに例えているんです
強い葉っぱでもないんですね
そういう葉っぱはいくらか揺れても頑丈で持ちこたえられますけどね
出たばっかしの葉っぱにはそんな力はないんですね
心はそんなものであると
揺れる 揺れる 揺れるきりがなく揺れる
一つの考え方でじーっといることはできないんです
何に揺れますかと言えばな
やっぱり様々な目に見えるもの
聞こえるもの それによって心は揺れ動く
それから妄想するでしょう
それによっても心が揺れ動くんですね
心は守り難い 堕落することですね
制御しがたい 心を放っておいちゃうと
すぐ堕落してしまいます
すぐ悪くなってしまいます
すぐ役に立たないものになってしまいます
これが普通とだと理解しておきましょう
これはお釈迦様の言葉ではドゥーラッカン ドゥンニワレアン
守り難い 制御しがたい
そういうわけで 我々にはこの決断力がないのは普通です
ないかあるかわかりようわかりません
何か決断したって もうすぐ変わってしまいますね
考えが ちょっとしたことで考え変わってしまいますね
そういうのは普通 どんな生命にもあることなんです
優柔不断 決断できない
わからないことは 人の心の
わからない わからないということですね
とは 人の心の普通の状態です
だから優柔不断で困ったなとかね
思ったっても それがそんなもんなんです
決断できなくて 決めることはできなくて
まあ悩んでいるっていうのは
これまた普通なんです
それからどうしようか
どうしようかとわからなくなっている
どうすればいい どうすればいいとかね
そういうまあ不安な状態になるのも
これは心の本来の姿なんです
だから私が言いたいのは
世間はなんか余計に決断力を持ちなさいとかね
優柔不断ではなくてしっかりしなさいとかね
まあ欲が強くとか 心が強くとそんなことを言うのは簡単だけどね
心の普通の本来の姿なんです
これは だからこのいい加減に言ってほしくないんです
悩むなかれとかね なんであんた早く決断してくれないのかとかね
早く決めなさいよとかね
そういうふうに責められていて
我々も優柔不断が悪いとかね
決断力がないのは悪いとかね
スイスイ気持ちが変わるの悪いとかね
自分を責めてますけど
気にしないでください
心はそんなもんなんです
どうしようもないんです
お釈迦様もそういうものである
これはコントロールしがたい
守り難いものであると
そこをわかった上で お釈迦様のアドバイスだから
それは大事に聞かなくちゃいけないんです
ただ単に一方的に押し付けて言っているわけじゃないんです
こういうことなんで 時々我々は事故を起こしちゃったり
体を骨折したりして もう 3ヶ月間ぐらいもうベッドで寝ていて
そこでもうまたリハビリしなくちゃいかんですね
で リハビリするときは病院で
その手伝ってくれる専門家の方々はよく知ってるんです
この人はもうこういうこういう病気で
足が動かない ここら辺はすごく痛いでしょうとかね
歩けないでしょうと しかし
歩けないで車椅子のままでは困りますよと
人間は自力で活動した方がありがたいではないか
ではリハビリしましょうということで
とても状況をわかった上でできないということをわかった上でリハビリさせるんですね
それどうなるかというと
見事にうまくいくんです
脳出血の場合でもね 半分もう
ほど まあ時々ね 働かなくなっちゃうでしょ
その時も結構リハビリで
それなりに体の部品が使えるようになるんですね
お釈迦様の立場はそういう立場なんで
人間の弱みをものすごく知り尽くした上で
強い人間になる道を教えているんです
だから世間の話とはちょっと違うんです
すぐ 判断して行動する人間もいるが
それは問題です でも私が言ったでしょ
判断できなくて 優柔不断で
もう何やこれやと言ったんだけど
たまたまいるでしょ パッと行動する
ありがたいね ありがたくないんです
言う前にもう行動しているんです
この人なら心が強くて
優柔不断がなくて 活発で明るくていいなと思うのは俗世間です
私はうるさいや この人とかね
迷惑やと やる前にしっかり考えてやってもいいかと聞きなさいという態度ですけども
もうやって終わってるんですね
なぜならば 目の前にある人参に飛びつく
そういう人々は 釣り餌をパクッと食っちゃうのは活発で明るい魚ですね
釣り餌 釣り竿の先っぽで餌がぶら下がっていると
一人の魚が あっ 美味しいや
これはパク もう一人の魚が
うーん 食べようかな どうしようかなと悩んでいる
どちらの方がいいですかね
やっぱり判断できなくて
美味しそうでもあるし
目の前にぶら下がってもいるし
でも普通は餌はそんな感じでぶら下がっているわけじゃないし
餌自身で食え食えと言ってくれるわけじゃないし
どうしようかと考えてる間に他の魚がそれ食っちゃって取られているんだからね
なるほど 取られたかと
まあいいや 別な餌を探しましょう
その魚 だからこのすぐ行動に飛び出す人々は
そんな感じで 目の前の人参にすぐ飛びつくだけであって
もう先を読めない あるいは無知で先を読める能力がない
どちらかですね そういう人々は
やればいいでしょという感じでね
あんたたちはもう腰が重すぎ
やればいいでしょという
私は何でもすぐやりますよという態度取るだけで
それも危険です とても危険です
はい 問題の始まりは この意欲がないこと
この仏教の心理学では
この意欲というやる気ですね
一般的に言えば よく使うんですね
このやる気っていうのは
ある特定のエネルギーなんです
心はエネルギーなんですよ
体は機械で 心はエネルギーなんですね
だからエネルギーはいろんな種類があります
それによって体がそれぞれの行動をするんですね
肉体の行動は至って簡単なんですけど
心の中でね いろんな行動をするんですね
それでこの意欲という
あの この欲という漢字書いてるんだから
これは欲の欲じゃないんです
意欲なんですね なんでこんな感じになったかよくわかりませんだけどね
だから一般日本語で言えばやる気なんですね
やる気なんですね これは特定のエネルギーで
それがなくなると何もできなくなるんです
はい 説明に行きます 生きることは心の働きです
私たちは生きている 生きていると言っていても
私たちの心がエネルギーですから
心が活動しているんですね
心が活動していることに生きていることやと言うんですね
生きる上で様々な行為
行動をしなくてはいけない
生きるということには
呼吸したり ご飯食べたり
喋ったり 座ったり 勉強したり
あれやこれやとかやらなくちゃいけないんですね
行動を引き起こすために
心の中に十分なポテンシャルが起こるのです
で それなんで意欲っていうのは心の中でこのエネルギーを出すんですね
動かすエネルギーを あの呼吸なんかは自動やと思ってるでしょ？自動じゃないんです
ただ これはとても大変で
やらなくちゃいけないことだから
まあ一応あまり考えなくても我々はやってますけど
呼吸することにも意欲が働いているんです
それはすごく働いているんです
だから意欲はなんで呼吸の欲を感じないのかというと
もうやっちゃったんだから
そのエネルギーはもう完成するとか
もう完結 終了しているんですね
だから気づかないんですね
やりたいんだけどやれない時はエネルギー感じるんですね
何かやりたいことはあるんだけど
なかなかお母さんがダメと言っちゃうわ
社会がね の目を気になると
あの時はのやる気を感じるんですよ
子供たち 結構感じるんですね
だってやりたいこといっぱいあるんだけど
お母さんお父さんがダメダメダメばっかりですからね
それで子供の心の体の中でやる気だけ溜まっちゃって
どうしようかと それで管理できなくなってるんですね
だからダメというんじゃなくて
両親が知らないのは このやる気を消すことできないんですね
私の場合は 子供には一度もダメ
やめなさいと言えないんです
やる気を やる気って風船ね
ちょっと針を それで子供はやる気がなくて
ダメもダメだと言わないでやる気がなくなっちゃうんですね
言い方 簡単に言えば あんたこれやりたいの？これやったらこういうことになるんだけど
私は知ったことじゃないんだからね
見えないところでやってくださいとかね
これ みんなに怒られたりね
いろいろ結果になりますから
私が行きますから 見えないところでどうぞやってくださいと
今の子供たちならやる気がね
これやばいと思った瞬間でやる気が消えてるんですね
やめなさい みっともないとは言わないんです
だから まあ親たちは別に心理学のプロじゃないんだから
失敗するのでったことはないんだけど
で やる気が溜まるとわかります
だから私たちは呼吸することには欲がいらないと思っているのは勘違いで
やったんだから このエネルギーはもう発散しているんです
だから これは簡単な実験
いつでもいう実験ですけど
ちょっと 1 分  2 分ぐらい呼吸を止めてみてください
呼吸を止めてみると 呼吸したい
呼吸したいという欲が猛烈に出てくるんですね
それはご飯食べたいという欲よりは強烈ですよ
ご飯食べたい 音楽聴きたい
後回しにできない欲なんですね
今直ちにやらなくちゃいけない
だから強烈な欲なんです
呼吸したらそれは発散する
また新たな欲が生まれて
また次に呼吸するんですから
例えば手を上げたいという考え
思考だけで手は上がりません
手を上げたいなと思っても上がりませんね
なぜエネルギーが足らないんです
手は重いんだからね 足が重いんだからね
足を上げたいなと言ったても上がりませんよ
朝よくあるでしょ？私にもあります
起きなくては 起きられませんね
起きなくてはという気持ちが入ったんだけど
起きられませんね なんで起きるというエネルギーはまだ足らないんです
それでいろいろもう我々はね
あれやらなくちゃ これやらなくちゃ
時間間に合わな 怒られるんだとかね
遅れるんだとかね 遅刻するんだとかね
いろんな概念が頭に input して興奮してもらって
やばいという気持ち 気持ちを作って
このまま布団泣いたらこれもう超やばいという恐怖感を感じて
サッと立ち上がるんです
それで十分な意欲が起きているんです
だから手を上げたいと思っただけでは手が上がりません
手はこういうふうに上がるのは
手を上げる意欲がエネルギーが生まれた時なんです
みんな生きてるから意欲があるのです
もうたいていにならない文章になってますけどね
だから誰一人も私にはそんな活発でいられません
そんな意欲がないやとかね
言ってもそれは嘘です
意欲があるんです 誰にだ
だって生きてるでしょうに
生きてるっていうことのは
相当欲が働かないと成り立たないんです
だから活発的な力ね まあそういうエネルギーはみんな持ってるんです
すべての生命の心に絶えず意欲が生じているんです
しかし 自然に起こるこのエネルギーだけでは十分ではないんです
我々には自然に欲があるんです
で 欲っていうのは起こる
消える また起こる 消えるなんですね
吸ったらその欲が消えて
そこで吐いたいという欲が生まれるんです
左足を上げたら上げたい
意欲が消えちゃうんです
それから下ろしたいという新たな意欲が生まれるんです
下ろしたらその欲が綺麗に綺麗になくなっちゃって
右足を上げたいという欲に
別な欲に変わるんです
そういうふうな意欲風に
意欲が生まれたり 消えたり
生まれたり消えたりするんです
それが自然の流れで 一つの意欲を保つということはまずありえないし
あったら危険です 例えば
足を上げたいという気持ちがあって
足を上げる意欲が消えません
どうします？上げるを上げろ
きりがなく上げようとするでしょうに
例えば ろうそくの炎に指が入りました
で ろうそくの炎を触りたい
触りたいという意欲があって
その意欲が消えません
だったら火傷して燃えるまでそのままでしょうに
ろうそくを触ってみたいなと触った瞬間で
もう痛いということで手を離すでしょうに
だから触りたい欲とまるっきり違う欲が直ちに生まれてこないと
もう安全に生きていられないんです
はい そういうことで 意欲っていうのは常に変化して
消え 現れて消える 現れて消えるものなんですね
意欲が現れて行動しないと
かなりイライラするんです
ご飯食べたいという欲ができちゃって
でもいろんな条件があって
ご飯食べられない やっぱりイライラしますよ
で 喉が渇いた 水を飲みたいなと言ったっても
なかなかもう自動販売機もなくて
もう水も手に入るところがなくて
ちょっと我慢しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
この我慢するっていうのは
この欲を抑えるでしょ
あれ 気持ち悪いんですよ
正直なところ イライラします
だから欲が起きたら それに適した行動をしなくちゃいけないんです
これが生きることである
理解してください で 考えてみればすごいシンプルなシステムなんです
しかし 生きることを仏教的に科学化すると
そういうものなんです
生物学的には生命の科学ないんだから
どうしようもないんです
生きるとはそうやってエネルギーを生まれて行動することです
しかし この 2 行目で書いたのは
このエネルギーだけでは十分じゃないんですね
時々もうちょっと作らなくちゃいけないんですね
わかりやすく言えば 子供は勉強しなくちゃいけないと知ってるんです
勉強しなくてはと でもやってくれないんですよ
勉強しなくちゃと思っただけでは勉強にならないんですね
だからもうちょっとこれ
チャージしないと ボルテージが上がらないと
この機械が動かないんです
だから十分チャージしないと
いろんなところで今  AED という機械がありますね
心臓にショックを与える電気機械がね
あれはすぐ使いません
人が心臓発作なんか起こしたら
まずパッドを貼って それからスイッチ入れたらチャージするんですね
チャージしたらもう一度ボタンを押せば
パチッと心臓に電気ショックを入れるんですね
そういうことで 十分なチャージが必要です
十分な電流電圧が必要なんですね
だから 勉強はしたい 勉強しなくちゃねとか思っただけではどうなってる？チャージは足らないんですね
その場合は この意欲をチャージして
行動に行くまで何とかしなくちゃいけない
はい それについてちょっと脱線して考えてみましょうか
我々はご飯食べたいという場合はチャージする必要はないんですね
お腹が空いたら何か食べていたら
もう何でも手に入ったものを食べちゃう
喉が渇いたら 誰かあんた喉が渇いてるんだから何やってるんですか？水を飲みなさいと言う必要ある？ないんです
子供に水を飲ませるということで苦労したことがある？ないんです
勝手に飲むんです というわけで
勉強しなさいと言ったらやってくれない
早く寝なさいと言ったらやってくれない
だから 2つありますね
チャージしなくても十分チャージがあって行動する
チャージしなかったらやってくれないという行動
2パターンあります 子供を例に出したんだから大人に関係ないではなくて
これはすべての我々にもあることなんですね
我々も言わなくてもやることはあるんだけど
言ってもどうしようかと
やるかやらないかと悩んでいる場合もあります
それは意欲のチャージなんですね
意欲を起こしたり 強化したり
制御したり 意欲を区別して
悪い意欲を捨てて良い意欲に入れ替えたりすることが必要です
この意欲に対するスタディはあんまり私は他のところで見つかったことはないんですね
仏教心理学では これはもう経典ではね
結構語られている世界なんですね
欲っていうことがあるんだよと
ただ単純に欲あっていいわけじゃないんですね
時々意欲をなかった 意欲を起こさなくちゃいけないですね
時々持っている欲を強化しなくちゃいかんですね
例えば勉強するという場合は
よく持ってますけど 足らない
これは強化しなくちゃいかんですね
それから私は皆さん 嘘をついてはならんとか
いろいろ戒律のことを言っているでしょうに
皆様の欲は嘘をつきたいという欲なんですね
嘘をつきたくないという欲はないんです
皆様と言ったっても これは人間像なんです
人間は嘘をつきたいんです
だから嘘をつくてはいけませんと
ついてはいけませんという新たな欲を作らなくちゃいけない
その欲は十分チャージしてないと思っただけで
やってないことになるんです
世の中そうでしょ 嘘つくの悪いとかね
ごまかすのは悪いとかね
金騙し取るの悪いとか言っているわりに
よくやってますね 悪いことはあかんやと言っているわりにやっちゃいますね
理由は欲がチャージしてないんです
ただアイデア程度で止まっているんですね
そこで制御したりって何ですかね
時々やりたいと思っても
やってはいけないことがあるんですよ
例えば突然怒り爆発する
そうすると前にいる人はぶん殴りたくなるし
もう手に取ったもので投げたくなっちゃうし
殺したくもなる場合もありますでしょ
あるいはもう怒鳴ったりしたくね
なりますよ その意欲があまりにも強すぎてやっちゃいますでしょ
すぐ相手を侮辱して怒鳴る
あるいは相手を殴る あるいは相手を殺す
そのような意欲が現れたら
ブレーキかけなくちゃいかんですね
欲に そこで普通は我々をお説教するんですね
人を殴ってはならんとかね
人に失礼な侮辱的な言葉を言ってはなりませんよとかね
このお説教はあんまり効き目がないんです
だから仏教はそうじゃなくて
この欲をチェックして
人を侮辱したくなりましたが
その気持ちをどうしようかと
で チェックするんですね
私は最近  1ヶ月間ぐらい前なんですけど
ある人が何かやったことで
これはあかんやと 二度とこんなことするな
なんだこれやと怒った方がいいなと思ったんですね
でも怒らなかったんです
あんたやったことは間違いやとも一言も言わなかったんです
それに2日間 私はどうしよう
どうしようと考えていたんですね
怒鳴って怒鳴って怒りたいんだけど
やるのかやらないのか
やるのかやらないのかとかね
で いろいろ考えてデータを取って
じゃあやらないことにしますと
それで私は何したのかというと
もう怒った 怒鳴ったではないんです
怒ってはなかったんだけど
なんでそんなことするのかというね
あんた余計なことしまったよと
この人を躾けたかったんだけど
で やったことは余計やと
これから気をつけなさいよと
こうしなさいと言ったところでやってほしいやと
自分で考えてやるなよと言った
言いたかったんです それはアドバイスであって
怒りでもないし その人の役に立つ可能性もあります
しかし 私が人と喋ると
その人の性格やこれはチェックして喋るんだから
理解鈍い人にはかなり爆弾的に言うんです
この人にも爆弾を落としたように言わなくちゃいかんですね
それで考えて悩んだのは
私のきつい言葉に持ちこたえる精神力はあるのかと
落ち込んだらかわいそうやと
その人がやったことは間違いかもしれませんだけど
本人が悪いやってやったわけでもないんです
良かれと妄想してやったことなんですね
それも知っているんですね
だから 怒鳴るかないか
怒鳴るかやめるかどう悩んで
悩んで  2日  3日経ったら
まあいいや これはなかったことにしましょうということになったんですね
で 私たちにそういうふうな教育が必要なんです
ブッダの教育 で 怒鳴ってはならん
怒鳴ってはならん 怒鳴ってはならんと
この呪文のように唱えたってても
意欲が消えるか消えないかということは問題なんですね
怒鳴りたい意欲があったままで怒鳴らないで頑張るときついんですよ
ストレス溜まっちゃうんです
イライラするんです 酒飲みたくて飲みたくてしょうがないんですけど
まあ戒律ですからやめますと言うと
当然ストレス溜まるんです
友達に誘惑されると すぐすごくないもん
飲みたいという気持ちもあって
でも自分がやめたっていうことにしたんだからどうしようかとね
そこで自分がどこをチェックするかというと
この意欲のこと 意欲をチェックして
意欲をちょっと風船やと思ってね
ちょっと針を刺せば その意欲がパーッと消えて
ああ 気分爽快でやらずに済みます
そこで悪い意欲が生まれたら
そこはやめる能力は必要し
良い意欲を引き起こす技が必要し
そういうものは仏教では明確に教えてはあります
はい それからこの 2 種類の欲に入ります
根本的な意欲 根本的な意欲は単純に言えば生きていきたいという存在欲と死にたくないという恐怖ですね
これは根本的な衝動です
生きていきたい 死にたくはない
死にたくないというのは
死んだこともないのにね
あれは恐怖感で感じるんです
だから我々は現実を無視するんだけど
心は現実になんとなく気づいているんです
だから生きていきたいと言ったっても
こんな単純じゃないやとわかっているんです
ちょっとしたことで死ぬんだよということを知っていて
そこで恐怖感が生まれるんですね
この衝動は根本的 この 2つの衝動の強弱によって生命の生き方が変わるんです
だから子供にでも水を飲みなさいよと言わなくても飲む
お腹がすいたら何か食べてください
あんたお腹がすいたでしょ
って言う必要はないんですね
叫ぶんです お腹がすいた
すいた 早く出してくれと
これは根本的な生きていきたいという衝動ですね
だからその意欲を別に強化しなくても
ずっと持っているんです
我々 生まれてから一度たりとも呼吸しなくてはと思ったことがないでしょう
これは根本的な意欲で強烈にあるんです
減りません しかし この意欲にも強弱があるんです
生きていきたいことは根本的にあるんだけど
なおさら生きていきたいと気持ち育てる
怖いっていうことは普通にあるんだけど
このバカどもたちはわざわざ恐怖感を育てる
生きていきたいっていう気持ちは誰にだってありますよ
あるんだけど わざわざそれを強化する
何やそれと そうなってくると生き方が変わるんです
存在欲が激しい人間 この存在欲が激しいのは人間なんですね
動物は簡単に諦められます
この自然の出来事をいろんなテレビなんかで見ていると
このチーターとかね 獲物をね
何でしたっけ？ガゼルとかね
こういう動物を追っかけていくでしょ
動物は必死で逃げるんですね
ある日 ずっと頭に残っている場面があって
ガゼルの子供なんですけど
走る だからチーターにはまっすぐしか走れない
で この草食動物は目が両側にあるんだから全部見えるんですね
だから急カーブできて走ることはできます
肉食動物の目が前だから
ちゃんと狙いにピンポイントして走るだけで
横に行ったら見えなくなっちゃうんです
そうやってややこしいバランスなんです
自然は そこでこのチーターがこの群れに子供が入っちゃうと
群れと一緒に動くんだから獲物取れないんですね
群れから離れた方が頭がこんがらがっちゃって
どこに走ればいいかと子供がわからなくなっちゃうんですね
子供といってもかなり体力あった小さなガゼルでしたけど
それでなんとか群れの方でない方向にこの子が走っちゃったんですね
で チーターが後ろから追っかけていく
で 子供がもうあちらに曲がったり
こちらに曲がったり いろいろ噂をするんだけど
お母さんがいるところに
群れがいるところに行きたいんで
もうわからなくなっちゃったんですね
そこでチーターが後ろから行って
爪も何も出さないで 手でタッチしただけ
手でこうやってタッチしたんですね
それだけで私はもうもう読めてるんです
もう場面できる出る前に
私は今どんな反応するのかと
そのまま凍るんです もう何も動かないんです
体 筋肉 いわゆる生きていきたいというあの衝動がすぐ消えちゃうんです
そうすると走りなさい
危険ということが消えちゃうんです
で 体動かないんです そのまま凍っちゃって
そのまま止まったんですね
それで目にも恐怖感も何もない
もう命は捨てた それで
あのチーターが何のことなくゆっくりと首をカチッと噛むんですね
それでシステムはストップするんですね
なんか言えばわからないんですね
悲しいか もう命ってそんなもんなんで
残酷ですからね しかし
人間だけは違うんですね
諦めませんね もうわざわざチャージするんで
生きていきたいという気持ちを
だから人間どうするのかと
他の生命の生きる権利さえも奪って
恐ろしい存在で生きているんです
生きる環境まで破壊するんです
生きていきたいゆえに
森を破壊する 山を破壊する
湖を破壊する 海を破壊する
魚を全部トローラーという
なんとかという底網 なんとかっていう底引き網で片っ端から取って
食べるものだけ取って
他全部捨てちゃう そういうわけで
この衝動の暴走ということを学んだ方がいいんですね
存在欲が暴走しているので
財産を獲得することに必死です
これ 人間 このリスとか一部の動物以外は食べ物を保管しないんですね
それを見たら当たり前で
冬は何も食べるものないんだから
木の実とか持って行って
どこかどこかで隠して置いておくとかね
それはすごくかわいいんですよ
リスとかね 木の実を持ってきて
あちらこちらあちらこちらって埋めておく
見つけたら埋めておく
そこで冬はお腹が空いて出てきて
どこかちょっと掘って木の実一つ食べる
それであの子たちが自分がたくさん植えてるんだからね
忘れてるんですね 忘れてるよりはもう冬が終わったら
まあ普通自然なものを食べようとする
それで あの種がそこから芽が出てますよ
だから あいつは欲張りややと言えないでしょうに
食べる分よりはあちらこちらで隠しておくんだけど
それが必要なことになっているんですね
ですが 後で食べますということで隠すんだけど
それで昨日 木の実の方もあなたに食べられなかったら
芽を出して新しい命を作りますよということでしょうに
人間どうですかね 一日何トン
本当に高級食べ物を捨てているんですかね
食べられる すごくいい食べ物
それから我々人間の文化を見ると
人間の文化っていうのはもう一般人の文化ですよ
金を儲かることなんです
いくらあっても持ってほしいという気持ちがありますね
私たちに これいい例 昨日ネットで見たんですけど
スリランカの前の政府のある大臣の話で
そいつは野党側の党のメンバーでしたけど
政府側に入りまして まず何とか逃げて地方議員になるんです
で 貧乏な人で オートバイは 1台は持っていたみたいです
そこで半年  1年でこの地方の議長になったけど
それから国の普通の国会議員
国会議員になりまして
それからもう大臣にまで格上げしてもらって
で 大統領があの人のことは何でもさっさとやってあげたりする
なぜならば 世界一恐ろしい役人なんです
会社作るは作るは もう政治家に禁止なんですけど
そこでオートバイ一つだけあった人は
半年ごとに新しい車を買うと
車も何台あるかもわからない
それで最後になってくると
この人は飛行機会社まで持っているんです 5
6年以内で バカでかい飛行機一つは空港に止まったままで
何かって会社経営できなくなっちゃって
で なんかだから国にものすごい金払わなくちゃいけない
だから自分が儲かって儲かって
だから誰かさんがね まあ知り合いがね
どれぐらい家持ってるかというと
南部にホテルは 6つありまして
家が２つで コロンボは家
は 五五件あって 何々地方にこれ稼げられないんです
ホテルはあるわ 至る所に家作るわ
土地買うわ 何のため？これ国民の金なんですよ
全部もう汚職の金なんです
政府は倒れちゃったんだけど
この政府を応援してた連中が調べることに反対するんです
調べないでくださいと
で 私はそこで何を読み取るかというと
かと 貧乏なアホがね 大事に政治家になったら儲かれる
簡単に儲かれるんだと思ったところで
これでブレーキが壊れるんですね
儲かるわ 儲かるわ 何のことかと
これはと ああいう人々はもう明確に病気なんです
だから私たちにとってもこの危険性ありますね
個人的に自分に素直に聞いてみてください
あんたはお金いくらあったら足りる？満足すると言ったら
数字が出たらありがたいんですよ
私の場合は1000万ぐらいあればもう死ぬまで大丈夫やとかいう人々はそんなに悪人じゃないんです
まあ 1億あればもう文句ないんだよと
時々いるんですね お金ってのはいくらあっても足らんでしょう
なくなるもんだからといったら
もう恐ろしい だから まともな人間というのは
あのね 私は毎日ちゃんと何か食べて生きてるし
このままではね 死ぬまで食べていられますから
いらんやと お金はと もうやることもないしね
思う人々は本当に立派な人間なんですね
財産を守るために他を破壊することもしますね
強盗するわ もう殺すわ
裏でからくりやるわ 落とし穴作るわ
この会社同士とかね 名誉欲
権力欲 支配欲なども存在欲の化身です
そこで人間の場合は名誉が必要
必要し 権力が必要やと
支配権 社長になりたいんですね
課長部長になりたいんですね
政治家になりたい 議員さんになりたいと
議員になったら何か何かコミッティーの会のメンバーになりたいと
どんどんどんどん大臣閣下閣まで上がりたいとかね
それって権力欲なんですね
病気でしょうね なぜならば
なんで？と聞いたら答えがないんだからね
そういうのはこの存在欲
私は生きていきたいという意欲があらゆる方法で成長して暴走しているんです
成長じゃなくて だからこれは暴走なんです
生きるためにそこまで必要かと考えられないんです
だから仏教のなんて解毒さえもいたって簡単
あのね あんたにそれなかったら生きていられないというだけです
安倍さんにしたって あの安倍さん
あなたそれにならなかったら生きていられない
死ぬ？といったら それには答えノーでしょ
だから生きていられない程度は正常なんです
その以上の存在欲は暴走なんです
だから我々 今 現代社会
現代社会っていうのは暴走社会なんですね
欲の 恐怖感が暴走すると
戦争 テロ行為などまで進みます
怖いという感じが出てくると
もうテロリストまで現れます
生きていきたいために行うこれらの行為によって
肝心な生きることさえもできなくなるのだと理解しないんです
この人間どもは生きていきたいためにボロ儲けするんだけど
それによってあんたは生きていられなくなりますよと
逮捕されて終わりますよってことは理解しないんです
殺されて終わっちゃいますよと
テロリストたちが恐怖感でテロ行為をやるんで
自分たちも死ぬでしょうに
戦争しちゃうと 国のためにといったっても生きるためでしょ
結局は破壊されて 自分も死んで
財産も壊れちゃって終わっちゃうんです
だから仏教は馬鹿っていう言葉は至って簡単に
愚か者やと 世間の流れに乗るなよと
というのも仏教という立場なんです
どうぞ自由にやってくださいと
俺はやらんやと 普通に生きていられるのにできない
それ理由は この衝動の暴走
言葉を入れ替えると欲の暴走
自害する行動まで恐怖の暴走です
だから自害活動をやっている人もたくさんいますね
あれも欲が暴走しているんです
火を温める必要はないというテーマに行きます
根本的な衝動はすべての生命にあるので
あえて育てる 成長させる必要はありません
だから火を温めるような感じなんですよ
火を温めるバカがいないでしょ
火は暖かいんです 火が他のものを温めるんであって
何やってるのかと もうあべこべなんです
生きていきたいという気持ちが常にあるんです
これ なんで暴走させるんですかね
そういうわけで ブッダのアドバイスは
生きていきたいとか 敵を倒したいとかね
忘れなさい そんなのはと
生きていきたいと思わなくたって
あんたは生きているんだよと
その程度で十分やと 恐怖は怖いということは当然ありますから
まあほどほど気をつけて
それで終わり ほどほど気をつけて
それで楽やと あなたは
もし暴走したならば それを制御する必要はあります
そこで 今日のテーマで私から皆様に聞きたがっているのは
このやる気を引き起こして
もう何をするべきかとしっかりわかって
抜群に活発に生きることでしょう
私は反対言っているんです
これ違うんだと あまりにもしがみすぎて
なんかもう生きていきたいと活動しているならば
ちょっと待ったと 必死で仕事をするはもう仕事をして
残り時間でパートタイムもやるわとかね
で 貯金をするわとか ちょっと待ってよと
やりすぎやと あれもやるは
これもやるとかね いるでしょ
そういう人間も いろんなことに手を出してきりがないんですね
これがこの欲が暴走して
存在欲がね 生きていきたいということは
そこなくてもちゃんと動いてるんです
例えば雪で人が滑ったとしましょう
滑ってくると 山とか斜面で
さらにスケートとか別なんですけど
それに頑張ってスピードを上げる
死にますよ 何とかして
あの雪で滑ってるんだからスピード暴走するんですね
それはなんとか自分で止める必要があるんです
滑ってもいい 山からスピードをいろいろなことをして
何かちょっと捕まったり
捕まっても捕まらないとかね
なんとかなんとかね 体を横にしたりとか
縦にしないでとかね いろいろ工夫してスピードをコントロールしなくちゃいけない
最後に落ちる時はちゃんと縦になって足で止めるようにしますとかね
ここら辺ぶつかったら死にますから
そうやって頭を使って滑っている人が
あの瞬間の時間で暴走を制御する必要はあります
これで私にどうやって暴走させるのかと説法設定くださいと言っても
それはできないんです
ですから この生きていきたいという気持ちはすぐ暴走するんです
はい 次 ここは世間が間違っているところです
ここは世間が間違っているんです
感情が暴走している人なら
やるべきことがわからないと言わないんです
我々の感情がもう暴走しているならば
感情と言ったっても 欲と言ったっても
衝動と言ったっても同じことです
ほぼ同じことです つながってますからね
そこは暴走しているならば
誰も私は何すればいいかわからないと悩んでないんです
なんかやっちゃいますよ
仏教とにかく迷惑行為とかあるでしょうに
家の中でも もう家にいる人々は迷惑行為をするわ
もう法律的にもね 迷惑行為という定義のものもあるし
もう時々人がやっていることは迷惑をやっていることも当然あるでしょうね
ああいう人々には欲を育てなさいとかね
いらん 迷惑です どこかで少々でも暴走しているんです
はい 仏教の話になります
仏教では無明 渇愛 貪瞋痴
煩悩 束縛などの用語で
生命の根本的な存在欲について明確に語られています
この本来持っている欲について
こういう用語で分析して
分析して詳しく教えられてあります
しかし 存在欲を掻き立てることではなく
根絶することを推進しているんです
仏教は反対を言っているんです
存在欲を掻き立てましょうと
あんた 死ぬのは悔しいでしょう
神様は信仰しなさい 天国に行ったら永遠にいられますよとか
そういう恐ろしいことは教えません
結果も恐ろしい だって役に切りがないんだから
ではなくて 存在欲を根絶しなさいと
これ暴走したら危険で
普通にながらでも危険なものでしょうに
それには私たちが期待する欲よりも桁違いの欲が
欲と理性が必要です 存在欲そのものをなくそうというのは
並の人間にできることじゃないんです
これはできるようにお釈迦様は指導しているんです
だから どんな人間であろうとも
ブッダの道を歩めば超人間になるんです
すっごく活発で すごい意欲のある
やることどうでわからないということではない人間になります
でもそれは存在欲ではないんです
別な素晴らしい意欲が生まれるんです
はい ちょっとテーマについて悪口って言いましょうか
するべきことがわからない
なぜこのような問題が問題が起こるのでしょうかと
なんでするべきことをわからないと言うんですかね
感情が混乱しているんです
自分にあるのは存在 あるのは欲か怒りか
自分ではわからないんです
これからそういうするべきことをわからないと悩んでいる方々がいるならば
これから自分の心をチェック入れてください
自分の心に何か気持ちがあるんだけど
それ欲でしょうか 怒りでしょうかと
よくわからないんです
経済的に豊かな環境で生きているから
明日何を食べようか 食べるものが手に入るのでしょうか
病気になったらどうしようかなどの心配はない
ただでただでさえ生きられる環境でしょうに
ただではないでないんだけど
簡単に生きられる環境にいるでしょう
だからどうすればいいか
どうすればいいかと悩み始めになるんです
これ 反対に言えば 怠けても生きられる状態なんです
例えば 日本の社会は怠けてもなんとか食べていられますね
だから余った時間にどうすればいいかという問題が出てくるんです
自分以外の世界 社会が広すぎるので
やりたいこともできることもできると思えるものも複数あります
今 我々はものすごい広い社会
世界で生きているんですね
そこであれもやりたい
これもやりたい これもやりたいという
やりたいものの選択がたくさん出てくるんです
なんか気に入っちゃって
欲が出て 見栄を張って
あれもやりたい これもやりたいと
それから自分にできることは何なのかと言ったら
まあやればこれもできる
やればこれもできる やればこれもできると
また選択 出てくるんですね
いくつか これでわからなくなります
するべきことはわからないんだと
頭が混乱しているだけなんです
そこでこの環境のことをまた書いたっけ
書いてなかったら普通にいます
あ 書いてないみたい この我々は豊かな環境でいるんだから
怠け者になっちゃって
活発性が消えちゃって
明るさも消えちゃって
ただボケーっとしている状態になっているんです
これ苦しいんです 何すればいいかな
わからないなとかね それで考えてください
この貧しい国 国 貧困の国
国 その問題は現れません
必死で戦わないと食べるものは出てこないんです
朝から晩まで苦労したっても
お腹いっぱい食べるものは手に入らない場合もあります
この中東の IS  IS というね
素晴らしい組織の国に組織にとられている国々では
命を守ることは大変ですよ
子供たちは機関銃を持ってきて殺そう
だから神様のために 神様が腰抜けだからね
だから外へ出た時でも
もうすごくしっかりしないと
皆様みたいに まあどういいですね
なんとなくって感じでは生きてられませんよ
ということで この生きること
存在欲そのものに問題がある場合は
意欲がいくらでもあります
例えば食べ物ない すごくお腹が空いてる
5 6人の５ 6人がいるとしましょう
あと一人分ぐらいの 例えばまあ米あげる
まあ 1キロぐらい この 5 人がいきなりパッとこれ取っちゃって
カッパスですよ 取ろうかな
申し訳ないなとか そんな考えてないんです
ありがとうございます
ご丁寧に 我々はお腹が空いていたんだから
米 1 キロ持ってきてとかね
そんな余裕もないんです
あの米袋 あの 5人もパッと取ろうとして
袋も破れちゃって 米も落ちちゃって
一粒一粒拾う羽目になるんです
あれは皆様方は行儀悪い
悪いことで言ってはいけませんよ
そういう人々は生きることで必死なんです
だからどうするべきかと悩む余裕がないんです
あ 米がある 取ろう それで終わり
だから この社会がいくらか豊かになって
24時間コンビニやってるんだから
いつだってご飯食べられる
24時間も弁当売っている
だからまあ そういう何て言いますか
考えなくていけない 計画を立てなくちゃいけないという項目は全部取り上げられているんですね
お腹が空いたら それもまあ
3 2 分  4 4 分  5 分歩けばコンビニで住宅
あれあるでしょ もうビルね 10
階  10 階建物  50 15 階建物とかね 1
階は店だから エレベーターで降りるだけ
だから家族の中の子供でも
お母ちゃんご飯食べてくるって言って
エレベーターで降りて
コンビニに入っておにぎり買って食べて
そのままエレベーターに上がることできるんだから
だから そういう風に この生きるということに気づかない環境で現れるのは馬鹿なんです
無知な人なんです 鈍感な人々なんです
鈍感になっちゃって 危機を感じないことになっちゃって
どうすればいいかわからない
わからないと言うんです
それは私にもどうすればいいかと答えることもちょっとできないんです
一応答え出してやりますけどね
生きることは何か あ ちょっと待って
それから教育の問題 これ言わなかった
教育は金儲けという単純な目的を持っているので
この世で成功することだけ
皆生きる目的であると思っているんです
よう金儲けで成功しない
だから勉強しなさいと
しっかり知識あったらすごい給料の高い仕事を見つかりますよ
それだけ あんまりにも情けないでしょう
そんなのは でもそれが正しいと思っているんです
だから我々は教育を受けているんだけど
結局は人間にならないんですね
情けない もう能力のない
やる気は引き起こせない人間になるんです
生きることはことは何か
どのように生きるべきか
人間が持つべき優れた生きる目的は何なのかを教えてくれません
これは教育の仕事なんです
数学を教えるだけじゃ
科学を教えるだけじゃないんです
生きることって何でしょうかと
我々はどのようにこの世界で生きればよろしいかと
生きる上でやるべきことは何なのかと
大人になったらやらなくてはいけないものは何なのかと
やってはいけないことは何なのかと
立派な人間に生きるということはどういうことかと教えてくれないでしょうに
成績上げなさい それで終わり
あなたの成績ではね いい大学に大学に入れませんよとか
それだけなんですね 最低道徳倫理は命に欠かせない程度のもの
欠かせない程度のものさえ教えてくれません
最低ね 道徳倫理を守りなさいよ
君たちは と これは命に欠かせないと
道徳倫理を失くしたってもいいんです
道徳がなければ生きていられませんよと
五義僧がなければ生きやっていられませんよと
それぐらいの学校は教えてくれない
親も教えてもらったことないんだから
困るだけで教えてあげられない
そういうわけで 人間にはなんか生きていられなくなっているんです
次 意欲の揺らぎ勉強しましょう
心が揺らぐの 揺らぐので意欲も揺らぎます
当然です 生き延びるために必死で戦わなくてはいけない環境では
意欲が弱くなることは少ない
それは説明しました 厳しい環境でいるときは
例えば皆さんはたまたま森の中で 1 日過ごさなくちゃいけない
テントを張って元気です
その夜は そこら辺 熊もいるとかね
毒蛇もいるとかという情報が入ると
テントの中で元気で生活します
変でしょ？明るいんですよ
その時は落ち込まないんです
活性化してるんです 全部
それで森の中でちょこちょこっと音が聞いただけで
目がパッと目が覚めて
ちょっと聞いてるんです
ああ 朝寝られ 寝られない
起きられなかったとか
あんな気持ち悪いこと言わないんです
今日はもう 6時に起きたんだけど
なんかね 起きられなくて
起きてみたら 1時間も経っちゃって遅刻しましたよと
あんな情けない恥ずかしいこと言えないんです
森の中でテントで寝ている場合は
ちょっと枝がサラサラと音しただけで
パチッと目が覚めちゃって
何なのかの音はと 大丈夫みたいと
また寝ると その時 意欲を刺激しなさいと
頑張りなさいと誰も言う必要はないんです
戦わなくても生きられる環境では
意欲がたびたび弱くなります
これは皆様にある問題で
日本みたいな社会にある問題で
アメリカでも少ないんですよ
殺されますから ちょっとしたことで
だからこの平和でいるし
食べるものもコンビニに行けばあるし
もう問題ないんですね
そうなってくると 意欲がたびたび弱くなる
頑張る気が現れたり なくなったりする
心は曲者なので その状態に慣れてしまいます
これだけ危険です やる気がなくなった
ご飯食べても 今日は何なお腹も空いてないし
食べなくてもいいしとかね
で ご飯食べる時間なんですけど
まあいいや 今日はもう寝るという風になってくると
どんどん心って曲者なんです
一回やったことは覚えておくんです
そこで怠けに慣れてしまうんです
意欲がない状態に慣れてしまいます
これは危険です わからないではなく
やりたくはないなんです
これがポイントです するべきことはわからないということは
ちょっとおかしい 本当はやりたくはないんです
意欲が減っているんです
あの禅のエピソードなんですけど
ある禅師が寺の何か一生懸命仕事をしているんですね
庭のあれきれいにして
落ち葉を取って もう頑張っているんですね
老師が で 若い弟子がいて 「
先生 私は何をすればいい？」と聞いたんです
そしたら老師の答えは 「
あのね お前にやる気があれば聞かないよ 」
ということで答えた だから若い弟子がもともとやる気がないんですよ
老師を助けてあげて 老師と一緒に修行したくないんです
だから言われたらやりますという態度でしょ
老師が 「ああそう じゃあ君
このここら辺の落ち葉を全部拾って
それからこちらに入れて
この枝を切って そちらに水を 」
そうやってプログラムを教えたらやりますよ
丁寧に でもあんなのはインチキです
だから禅世界も心の世界だから
あの禅師が素晴らしい答え
完璧な答えです 君はやる気がない
やる気がある人は やるべきことは何かと人に聞かないと
で 私はもう禅宗のエピソードに載っちゃったんです
これ正しいんです その禅のエピソードは
するべきことがわからないとは
何もやりたくないという気持ちの表れです
やりたいという気持ち
意欲があれば やって欲しくないものまでやってしまいますよ
普通そうでしょう 子供たちはね
もう意欲が旺盛でしょう
だってお母さんが全部押さえるんだから
溜まってるんですね だから子供はやって欲しくないものでもやっちゃいます
意欲がある人は次に何をしようかと探すんです
やる気がある場合は 周りを見てどうすればいいか
何をしよう すぐ見つかります
だって私はこちらにいて
大阪でやるべきことを思い出さないでしょ
やる気がある私はこの舞台の上にいるんです
だから私はどうすればいいかとわかるでしょうに
皆様も同じなんです あ
大阪でもちょっと前でいうお寺があるんだけど
あれ掃除した方がいいなとか思いません？だって今こっちこちらにいて
大阪のお寺の掃除できんでしょうに
だからやるべきことはわからないというのは無意味なプレースなんです
意欲を引き起こしてほしい
何かやりましょうよと
では何でしょうか？と
周りにあるんです 意欲がなければ
するべきことは浮かぶ
浮かばす 浮かぶはずもありません
だから意欲がなくなっちゃうと
するべきことは浮かばないんです
それで仏教の提案は 自分の心の中を見て
この意欲を育てることなんです
しかし 最初は育てるなよと言ったんです
存在欲と恐怖感は そんなのは育たなくてもあるんだよと
だから別なプログラムが必要なんです
はい そういうわけで ちょっと皆さん疲れているような顔か
まるっきり理解したくないという顔か
どちらかわかりませんだけど
ちょっと 10 分休憩いたします
はい では始まります  はい
あの これからあの意欲の管理でやるべきことは
私はテーマから外したんですね
意欲があれば やるべきことはもう目の前にあるんですからね
それは大げさな問題ではありません
で 我々に必要なのは意欲をどう管理するのかという
で 具体的な話に入ります
まず 世間的意欲 世間的意欲とは
生きるために必要な力です
これは世間 世間的意欲というんですね
生きるために この世で生き延びるために必要な意欲
力 人間は仕事をして生計を立てなくてはいけない存在であると理解しましょう
これ 何かを教える時 ちょっと間違いがあるんですね
人間で生まれたら 誰でも何か何かしら仕事をしなくちゃあかんです
この仕事の定義がわかってないんですね
仕事とは同じ 種類の生命に何か貢献することなんです
だって我々は人間という種でしょ？だから
人間という種である我々は人間に何かを貢献する
そうすると その人間が私たちを助けてくれる
これが仕事なんです これ
間違ってどこかに会社で仕事をして金儲かることやとか
そうじゃないんです そういうわけで
赤ちゃんも私の定義では赤ちゃんはちゃんと仕事をしています
サボりません 仕事は じゃあ赤ちゃんどんな仕事かというと
赤ちゃんがね 結構お母さんを楽しませてあげているんです
お母さんにこの世に存在しないぐらい幸福感
幸せを与えているんです
これが金では計算できないんですよ
ある女性に 1,000万円のネックレス
ダイヤのネックレス あれ
指輪と 何でしたっけ？輪っか何かあげたっても
あれほどは喜びませんよ
自分が産んだ子供を見て感じるあの幸せ
だから赤ちゃんがお母さんのそばに来るともうじゃれちゃうわ
手足でいろんなことをやっちゃうわ
お母さんを噛んだりするわ
いろんなことをやって
ちゃんと仕事をしているんです
ただおっぱい吸って寝る
まだ目が覚めてお腹が空いたら泣く
それでまたおっぱいって寝るだったら面白くないんです
だから そういうたまに仕事をしない赤ちゃんもいるんです
いるでしょ？子供捨てられたとか
あんまりないんだけど
いるんですね それでも赤ちゃんはどこかで
日本でもケース幾つかあったんで
どこか駐車場で赤ちゃんをタオルで巻いて置いておいて逃げているんですね
で 他の経済状態いろいろあったかもしれませんだけど
鬼の母ではなくてわからないんだからね
それで でも あの赤ちゃんが自分の仕事をしたならば
お母さんが元気になっちゃうと幸せを感じて
意欲が生まれちゃって育ちますよと
誰が何と言おうとも 気持ちになるんです
そういうわけで 皆様よく理解してください
皆様の仕事の定義を削除して
全部ファイルをね 復活できないという削除して
仕事とは自分の種類種に何かを貢献することです
そうすると我々人間だから人間に支えられて生きていなくちゃあかんです
会社に行ってやっていること同じことだ
例えば電車でホームで駅員の方々いるでしょ
結構いい給料もらってるでしょうに
私たちとかのは指をさして
あちらさって何やってるのかと
それだけでしょうにと
でも それも仕事なんです
なぜならば 我々は気づかない
安全対策たくさんあるんです
あれでもちゃんとね 乗ってる人は乗ってるか
まだ乗ってないのか チェックしているんです
ホームが曲がっちゃって見えない場合はモニターで見ているんです
電車が来る前にみんな白線の客前の前に入っているかどうかね
だから電車が来るんだよと
するとまあ OK OKと言って
もし起きれなかったらすぐあれで下がってくださいと言われるでしょうに
だから一回最近私はもう何も忙しくて
でも年寄りだから昔みたいにね
動かないしね 電車がもう扉が閉まるするんだけど
さっさと行って でもはめられる
挟まるのと分かって 挟まるの分かってはいたんですけど
スピード計算できるんだからね
ちょっとはめられてもう中抜きして入ったんですね
何か言われるともう分かっているんです
自分も昔は言われません
サッと入りますから 今はちょっとね
そんなにスピードはないんで
体には でも計算能力はあるんです
それでちょっと扉にはめられる
しも中に入れると程度は分かっていたんです
電車に乗って行ったら
放送でね 駆け込み駆け込み乗車は止め
とても危険なのでやめてくださいというイントネーションで
だから 私は勝手に死んだっていいね
たくさんの人々に迷惑でしょうに
だからその人が同じ種に貢献しているんです
それで給料もらってるんです
で 家庭にいる奥さんが仕事してない
すごい仕事をしてるんですよ
だから男性の方々 間違ってでも私が食わしてるんだよと言ったら
二四八時間以内で離婚されますよ
それはもうとんでもない嘘の言葉なんで
侮辱です です どんな忙しく仕事をしたっても
男性よりは家を守る奥さんが仕事をしているんです
直々命を守っているんです
会社で何かパソコンをいじったり
何か文章ファイルをあちらいって
こっちもう走行の管理したりとか
それは直々命に関係ないでしょうに
だからそういうことで
我々は皆仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
で 皆様は在家だから仕事をして
それなりに適切な給料をいただいたいということはあるんですね
お釈迦様が我々に絶対何ももらうなよと説法しなさい
これはあなた方の仕事
それは無料でただで説法しなさいと
なぜならば 価値は計り知れないんだと
この教えるものの価値はね
だから金もらったら仏法を侮辱したことになるんです
では 我々は飢えていることがありますかね
問題はないでしょう 何に困ったっていうことはないんです
だから決まってる 給料をもらって
説法一回一時間くらいぐらいとかね
決まってなくて まあどこでも頼まれたら行って説法する
しかし 自分が人類に同じ種にね
何かを奉献している これで考えてみれば
結構困ること何もなく生きているんですね
だから月給いくらかということは問題ではないんです
ちょっと考えがもうちょっと直した方がいいんで
理性的に 例えば退職を辞めた人が
まあただ公園をきれいにするボランティアで
それなりにご褒美が返ってきますよ
結局は そちら公園座っている人と挨拶をするし
それで仲良くなるし そうなってくるとね
公園には花壇作りたいんだけどねとか
おじいさんじゃあやってください
持ってきますよと 物は必要なものはとかね
で そういう風に そこですごくいい美しい世界が現れてくるんです
いろんな人と一緒にご飯食べたり
弁当を食べたり みんないろんな道具
品物を持ってきて で 例えばボランティア組織あるでしょ
NGO とかね あっちで NGO ボランティアだから無料で奉仕するのは当たり前でしょうに
でも関係ある人々はそれで結構収入を得て生きているんです
そういうわけで 人間なら仕事をしなくちゃいかんです
だから なんで同じ種と言ったんですかね
じゃあ毎日猿にバナナあげることにしてください
悪いことじゃないでしょ
でも自分の金がなくなるだけでね
猿さんたちは親しくしてくれるかもしれませんだけど
自分の命を助けるためには何もしてくれませんね
できません だから仕事の場合は同じ種でなければ成り立たないんです
時々この神社仏閣とかの神がかりの人々でしょ
神社なんか神様の嘘ばっかりやりやがっちゃってね
まあ干物をあげたり 大根を差し上げたり
米いろんなことをかなり厳しくやってますよ
神様は何もくれませんよ
種が違うんだから 我々人間がその神社に
寄付をして いい給料もらってますよ
神社さん 神社の神主さんも結構贅沢にいます
だから具体って理性で言えば
一般人が神様の 何て言いますか
祝福とは言わないね その場合はもうなんか欲しい
で 神主さんがなんだらかんだらなんだらかんだら言って
それをなんとかやってくれる
とても丁寧にお祀りをやって
お供え物を持って行ってお祀りをやる
それでああ 今年も商売繁盛するんだと一般人が思う
だから一般人がなんとなく気持ちよくなりまして
今年もよく頑張りましょうということになっちゃって
よかったでしょ そので
神社に必要なお金を払っているんです
だから 本当のところ 正直なところ
神様のお世話をしているんじゃないんです
あれは 神様のお世話をしているんだったら
どうしても神様からもらってくださいでしょ
あんた 神様と仲良しでしょうにとかね
私たちも幸せになりたくて神様にお願いしますから
あんたのことは先にやってくれるでしょうに
ないんですね やっぱり一般人が何かしてあげなくちゃいかんですね
そういうことだから 仕事の定義は同じ
一緒に貢献してあげること
だから 人間で生まれたならば
仕事をしたくないとか
言ってはならんではなくて
思ってもならんです 会社に入りたくないはいいんです
別に 親父は田んぼでしたけど
私は田んぼをやりたくないわ
それはいいんです 別に
あるいは具体的な何か仕事をやりたくないだけだからね
しかし 仕事をしたくないわ
思ってもならんです 自分のお父様がもう田んぼを作って
なんとか金もないし 朝から晩まで苦労しちゃって
もうもうなんかかわいそうで
息子に見える 俺はやりたくない
こんなのはと もっと別な
じゃあ電気屋さんになってやると
それはいいんです 電気屋さんになって
もっと金を儲けて お父さんを楽にしてあげると
だから必ず父親の仕事を受け継ぐってどうでもいい話で
抜群に頑張らなくてはいかん
それは私が言う必要はないんです
一応言いましたけど 人に迷惑をかけないで生きられるならば十分です
はい その場合も大げさに考えないでください
私の命が人に迷惑をかけてない
と思ったら 例えばもう 28歳あるいは 30歳のに
まだお母さんがご飯を作ってくれる
お父さんの給料で食べて寝ているんだったら
恐ろしい迷惑でしょ 犬はかわいがってもらう権利持ってますけど
もう 25 6  7  8歳の息子娘には食わせる権利ないんです
義務はないんです 権利ではなくて
親がアホだからやってあげてるんだから
この連中が犬猫よりも以下の態度をとるんですね
それで日本ではね そんなに子供が一人二人しかないんだから
親にもやることがないんだから
子供大人なのに勉強も終わっているのに面倒見てあげる
車買ってあげるとかね
鬼です あんなのは あんた車欲しい
いいですね その年で 車った方が楽しいよ
自分で買いなさい で終わりなんです
鬼の仕事もなくて 車買えない
知ったことはないんだと
言わなくちゃあかん だから子供は小さいとき育てる
大学卒業するまではまあ全部面倒見る
それからはい さようならと
一人で生活しなさいと言わなくちゃいけない
で そこでこの教育上いろいろトラブっちゃって
社会にそういう問題があるんですね
大学も出ているのに仕事に行かないとかね
会社に無理やり親 お父さんが入れちゃっても
1ヶ月とかで辞めちゃったとかね
まあうまくいかなくて辞めてもいいんです
私の言葉で言えば でもあなた
何か仕事をしなさい 時々若い人々は私にあれやこれやと相談に乗ってくると
私はどうしても もうこれはもう負けてる人やとわかるんですね
私は最初の質問は あんた仕事をしている？ですよ
いつでも だから いえ 仕事をしてない
ただ家にただ何もしないで生きているんだから
私は出家したいと思っているんだと
無理です あんたにも あんたに仕事をする勇気もないでしょ
仕事をする時のあの苦労を 1000倍かけたら出家生活やと
ちょっとコンビニなんかで仕事をするぐらいの苦労はできなかったら話にならんよと
だからタダで食って寝られると思ってるんで
出家したら だったら新興宗教とかに入るしかないんです
騙しやがって 金盗んで生活してあげれば
これは命捨てる世界なんです
一般の方々から何も期待しないんです
一般の方々は自分の孤独のために何かをしたら
まあ祝福していただくんだけど
くださいは絶対ないんです
何もなくて死んじゃってもいいというふうに覚悟しなくちゃあかんです
だからこの私はだいたい若い年少の人々がいろいろ問題あって
まずというのは 精神的なトラブルがある場合はアドバイスしますけど
とにかく嫌かもしれませんだけど
相手を殺したくなるかもしれませんだけど
仕事をしてくださいと
我慢して 収入が足らなくてもいいんだよと
何か仕事をしたっていうことが必要だと
それでなきゃ人間は完成しませんと
人間失格やと そういうことだから
その欲は皆様は まあまあ
もう別に若者ではないんだからね
まあ全然関係ない問題で
皆様にそういう若い人がいるならば
厳しく言って手放してください
この話を言ってあげて
だから迷惑をかけない程度で十分な人間できているんです
お母さんに迷惑をかけてない
お父さんに迷惑をかけてない
例えば生活保護とかなんとかあるでしょ
国全体に迷惑をかけているんだからね
それはちょっと恥ずかしいんですね
しかし 仕事できない問題がある
そういう方々のためにあるお金なんです
だから生まれつきね 精神的な病気を持って生まれる
何か障害を持って生まれるとかね
あるいは元気でいたんだけど
もうみんなもう亡くなっちゃって
一人二人一人ぼっちになっちゃって
体もすごく弱くて 自分で料理もろくにできない状態で
収入もゼロで そういう年寄りの方々はちゃんと生活保護をあげなくちゃいけない
無理にでも 強引にでも
若者は そういうことで
生活保護しても悪くないんですよ
人間みんな元気ってわけじゃないんだからね
世界制覇するほどの意欲は要りません
だからやるべきことはわからないと
人々はなんか妄想の世界で世界制覇しようと思ってるんですね
だから我々は具体的で
まあ私は人様に迷惑をかけないで生きてますで結構です
自分に充実感を得られるように仕事をする
それで見つかった仕事は
褒めれば褒めてもらわなくてもいいんです
自分で今日頑張ったと
今日 1 日は与えられた仕事をしっかりやりましたと
たとえ仕事中で苦労しても
怪我したっても 荷物落としちゃってね
怪我しちゃっても でも大丈夫
仕事はちゃんとやりましたと
そういう充実感が必要なんです
問題は避けられません
というのは 私の意味がわからない
タイトルの俗世間的な欲は
貪瞋痴をかき混ぜる 存在欲と恐怖の世界です
そこで俗世間の仕事のことを言ったでしょう
でも 生きていきたいという気持ちでしょ
収入がなければ生きられません
やばいという気持ちでしょ
だから私が前のページで言ったアドバイスしても問題が起きます
私は若者に あんた何でもいいんだから
仕事をしています 経験してくださいと言ったら
その人はそれで完璧じゃないんです
仕事をしているとまた問題が起こる
そこを問題起きてほしい
私は そうすると次のレッスンを教えられます
上司に怒られたとか 与えられた仕事量は 1 日で終了することはできませんでしたとか
いろいろあります やっと仕事に慣れてくると
別な仕事に回されたとか
そういう仕事をした上でトラブルを起こしたところで
次のレッスンがあります
こちら仏教では だから
この欲と恐怖のために生きてみよう
意欲を出して生きてみようと思ったっても
そこで問題が起こる 感情は激しく揺らぐものなので
それに伴って欲が揺らぐんです
今日は仕事で重労働でクタクタ疲れてきて
家に帰ってもう体も痛いしだるいしね
ああ 明日は行きたくないなと気持ちは生まれますよ
行きたくないなとかね
これ気持ちは揺らぎます
仕方がありません 自分が遅くまで仕事をする羽目になったと
家に帰っても 2時間しか寝ていない
またすぐ朝早く起きて会社に行かなくちゃいけない
結構大変でしょうね それで欲が飛んじゃうかもしれません
が 知ったことではありません
そういうのはあることなんです
次の日も会社に行かなくちゃいけない
健康に問題が起こらない限りは行かなくてはいけない
徹夜で仕事をして 次の日は車運転はやめてください
これはもう人様の健康まで問題になりますからね
そういうことで 元気で明るく仕事をする人にしても
元気で明るくて家庭を守っている奥さんにしても
やりたくないな こんなのは毎日ワンパターンで同じことでとかね
で 気持ちが落ちる場合があります
それが普通であると理解してください
やる気が消えても気にしないで
その状態を観察すると
その理由を発見すると
またやる気が現れます
例えば 毎日毎日 もう朝ご飯作って
皿洗って 昼ご飯作って
皿洗って 晩ご飯作って洗われて買い物行って
毎日ワンパターンで面白くなくなっちゃいますよ
で そうなってくると まあやりたい買い物に行きたくないなとかね
献立も思い出せませんとかね
それで何ですかと自分の心を見る
自分がこのワンパターンで
ロボットみたいに家族を守っていることにちょっと味気が感じていない
子供たちも美味しいとも言ってくれない
旦那さんは何一言も言ってくれないとかね
それで充実感が 特に家庭の奥様たちの場合は
それ大きな問題で 子供たちと旦那さんがこの充実感を与えてあげてないんですね
自分が美味しいものを食っちゃって喜んでいるくせに
苦労して作った人に 今日 1 日ご苦労様でしたと一言も言わない
それでも女性の女子たちは頑張りますけどね
そこで頑張るんだけど
結構金かかってるんです
だから世の中でね 一番金かかるのは女性でしょ
男性の服も安いし アクセサリーも使わないしね
デパートに行ったら 男性のセクションのほんのワンフロアの半分で
他全部女性のやられているんです
ちゃんと十分女性たちに充実感が与えてあげるならば
女性も男性も平等でビシビシ働くんです
ビシビシ仕事をするんです
経済状態で困っていることはなくなるんです
はい それはどうでもいいことにしてしまって
で やる気がなくなっちゃうと
例えば奥さんのケースでは料理を作るたくはないなぁと
でもみんなを私が育てなくちゃいけないでしょうにと
みんなの命は私の手にかかっているんだと
偉そうなことをやっちゃってもね
あの連中は感謝一言もなく
わがまま奔放でいるのは私のおかげですよと
私は生かしているんだからと
じゃあ頑張らなくちゃと
それでやる気が出てくるんです
他の仕事の会社の男性の場合も同じことで
もうやる気がなくなったとしたら
だからどうしましょうかと
上司の言葉が悪い 人間扱いはわからないとかね
この上司はあまり上司として資格は持っていない
アドミニストレーションはわからない
人間の管理はできないアホやと
だから上司がアホだったら
私が責任持って仕事を自己責任でやらなくちゃいけないんだと
いうふうに状況を判断するとできるようになります
上司に悪口文句ばっかり隠れて言ったっても
やる気がどんどん失うだけで
だからそこで前のポイント
仕事をしなくてはいけない
これも自分が充実感生まれるように
悪い言葉使ってください
自己満足 その言葉を使っちゃうと悪く言っちゃいますからね
充実感 自分で素直に充実感を感じるようにすれば大丈夫です
しかし 俗世間では問題起きませんとは思わないでください
問題は起きます 不安はあります
貪瞋痴の衝動で生き続けることができます
仏教がなくても生きていられますよ
だって生きてるんだからね
だって貪瞋痴で生きていられます
アメリカとかね 中東の国々とかね
エジプトとかね いろいろたくさんの国々 ISIS
にはめられているし 殺し合いやりながら生きています
で しかし 理性が働かないので必ずトラブルが起きます
理性社会ではないんです
日本みたいに安心してアメリカでは生活できません
ヨーロッパはできますけどね
今ヨーロッパもちょっと余計なことをしちゃってね
イスラム国国から逃げる人々をみんな入れちゃって
国民権を与えて その連中がもうフランスもイスラム国家にならなくちゃいけないというんですね
助けてあげているのに
それは私も認めません
人権は知ってますけど
宗教は自由っていうこともね
信仰は自由ってあることも知ってますけど
他人に迷惑をかける権利がないでしょ
それで人間失格なんです
だから結構ヨーロッパの国々で住んでいるイスラムの方々は結構大変なんですね
決まり破ってるんです
コーランのおかげで コーランのみが正しいと
だからフランス人は獣
ドイツ人は獣 獣の世界で命を守って生きているんだけど
そういうのは良くないと思います
まあ言いたかったのは
そういう宗教批判ではなくて
貪瞋痴だけの世界では明確にトラブルがあるんです
日本でももうなんとなく皆様が潰そう潰そうと思ってるんだけど
道徳があって 行儀作法がマナーがあって
これはもうほとんど仏教の文化からね
いろんなことを教えられちゃって
なかなか忘れられませんね
遺伝子に入ってるんです
だからご飯食べる時でもごちそうさまと言うし
何の意味かもわかってないでしょ
食べて終わったら ご飯を食べる前にいただきますと言うし
食べ終わったらごちそうさまと言うし
なかなかやめなさいと言ったってもやめられないね
あれは遺伝子に入ってるんです
それでこの正しい生き方は
仏教は潰しちゃったんだけど
仏教とするんですよ 心に入れておくんです
忘れないように 次の世代にも教えられるように
ですから この派手な組織仏教は私も嫌いですが
ちゃんと人のことを心配するところがちゃんと心の中に入っているんですね
だから日本は平和でいいんだけどね
トラブルは全くないわけじゃないんですね
他の外国の国々ではそうじゃないんですね
毎日毎日何かしらトラブルなんですね
アメリカで走っただけも撃たれるんだから
それで欲は奪う力で 怒りは破壊する力です
覚えてください これ 貪瞋痴の力
で 痴は先を考えないで判断に困らない弱みです
それは力ではないんです
力 2つと弱みが組み合います
とんでもない結果になるんです
判断に困る  困らない 困らない
やっちゃいますからね
無知な人は ちょっと考えると
どうしよう これでいいのかと考えるでしょ
だから判断に困らないとかって
なんとなくこれいい言葉で読めますけど
これはそれ まあ私の書き方はそんなもんで
これ この場合は判断に困らないとかアホって意味なんです
やる前に考えなさいと
ティンクビフォーユーリープでしょ
ことわざは 飛び込む前に考えなさいっていう
あるでしょ？なんとかイソップ物語の中で
あのキツネがね 井戸に落ちちゃったんですね
で 出てこられないんですね
そちらに頭の悪いヤギが来て
キツネってあんた何やってるのかと
この中面白いよと 見えませんが
葉っぱもあります 食べるものもね
誰も食べてないしね 自分があって食べないしね
飛びなさいよと 飛んでみたら
葉っぱもあって食べてね
ったらどうやって登るのかと
言ったら じゃああんたもう足で壁に
半分登ってくださいと
うん で ヤギがそうやってね
両足前の足上に立って立ったんですね
立ったらキツネが肩に乗って飛び上がっていったんです
そしたらヤギさんが 私が
お前はね 飛ぶ前に考えるべきでしたでしょ
それはと はい さようならと
だから この英語でよく使うシンクビフォーユーリープ
飛ぶ前に考えなさいと
それはないんですね 飛び込むんです
私たちはないんです その経験は
やらなかった方がよかったということは
ありますよ 誰にだって
この ３つの力が組むと
成功より失敗が多いんです
それは理解してほしい
欲怒りの欲を制御する
それから仏教の具体的なアドバイス
欲怒りで生きてはいけませんと
だから我々は この中東の国々で起きているような殺し合いをやったり
テロ行為をやったり それはしてはいけません
北朝鮮にいくらいろんな変なことを言われたっても
ミシン負けする必要はないんです
乗ったらダメです あんな怒りに
自壊です だから貪瞋痴の道を歩むなかれと仏教が言う
しかし 我々は 私 先に言いましたよ
貪瞋痴だけでも生きられます
しかし それは苦しみのトラブルの道です
大阪まで歩いて行けますよ
私は言うのは のぞみに乗りなさいなんです
同じこっちゃじゃないんだよと
弁当も食べられますからね
結構食べてるんだから
私にとってはまずいんだけどね
煩悩がある限り輪廻転生するので
必死になって生きて生きていきたいと貪瞋痴を刺激して意欲を作る必要はありません
どうせあるんです みんなに貪瞋痴が
だから死んでもまた転生するんです
再び生まれるんです どこで生まれるかわからないんです
生命はものすごい次元がたくさんありますからね
みんな命ですから ゴキブリも
だからどこかに行ってしまいます
エネルギーは だから 死ぬのは怖い怖いと思う必要もないんです
生まれるのは怖いと思った方がいいんです
だってゴキブリになったらどうする？わからないしね
だから生まれることを怖いと思いなさいと
仏教なんです 死ぬことはじーっと観察しなさいと
仏教は面白い 死ぬのは怖いとはないんです
死ぬことは観察する して穏やかな気持ちでいる
生まれることは怖いと思うんです
おめでとうじゃないんです
赤ちゃんが生まれたら
この子は勉強できるかないか
犯罪を起こすか起こさないかわからないでしょうに
これからどんな生き方をするのかと
かわいそうですよ  貪瞋痴を制御することに
なくすことに意欲を作ると安全です
それで安全が欲しければ
貪瞋痴のために来るんじゃなくて
貪瞋痴を制御する なくそうと意欲作るんです
あと新たに その意欲はないんです
それは新たに作らなくちゃいけないんです
生きる上のトラブルも消え
人格も向上します それで安全です
私は何のために生きるのか
私は欲 怒り 無知ってなくしたいと思っているんだよと
仕事をしながら欲がないように
怒りが起こらないようにと頑張ってますよと
仕事中は怒らないように頑張ってますよと
お母さんが子育てでは怒らないように頑張ってますよと
頑張ればすべて安全です
怒っちゃいますよとはダメです
そこでトラブルが消えます
人格も向上します この意欲が減る時は
その理由も復活させる方法も理解できます
貪瞋痴なくそうと思って頑張る
会社で怒らないように仕事をしようと思っている
頑張る 1日目はできたんだけど 2
日目で失敗した やる気がなくなっちゃった
やっぱり怒っちゃいますよと
で やる気が減る 当たり前
減ったらその人はすぐ
あっ わかります 昨日怒らなかったのに
私は今日怠けが入っている
わがままが入っている
相手を侮辱する気持ちが生まれている
相手を見下す気持ちが生まれている
だから怒鳴りたくなっているんだと
それで見えるでしょ それで今日も怒らないように頑張る
そうともやる気が生まれているんです
子供に怒らないでしつけするそうと思っているお母さんが強い
怒ったら子供の人権侵害しているんです
子供の命を見下しているんです
指令すればいいと あるいは自分が面倒くさくて
疲れて疲れて 面倒くさくて
あ なるほど 私は疲れきっている
私がストレス溜まっている
私のストレスは 私は怒りで子供にぶつけたと
で 理解できる それですぐやる気が生まれてくるんです
次のポイント 現在に集中する
心は過去と将来という幻覚の中で働いている
それが存在欲と恐怖の世界です
心を持っているのに 心は過去にいるか将来にいるか
過去と将来っていうのは存在欲と恐怖の世界なんですね
やめてください そんなのは
紛れもなく危険なことなんです
だから 意欲も何をするべきかもわからなくなります
だって 過去のことで何を何をすればいいか分かるはずがないでしょ
過去だ もう終わったんだから
もう何もできんでしょ
将来は現れてないんだから
将来のことをどうすればいい
どうせあるな ないんです
そんなのは だから我々の頭が過去の幻覚
将来の幻覚に働いていて
忙しいんだから やるべきことはわからないんです
本当はやるべきことはないんです
それは関係ないの 心は現在に集中させて
あ  2回書いてますね させておくと
意欲は失わないんです
心を現在目の前のことに集中させる
そうすると いつでもやるべきことあるんです
これやって はい 終わった
はい これやらなくちゃと
はい これからこれやらなくちゃと
現在現在現在です 現在は具体的です
やるべきことあるんです
それから 3番目のステップ
高度な目的 学校と世界が言っている目的ではないんです
何か高度な目的があれば
意欲が現れます 自分が設定した目的はかっこよくて立派でクールで
そうするとやる気が出てくるんです
金持ちになるのではなく
理性のある知識人になること
いいんじゃない？権力財力ではなく
生命に優しい謙虚な人間になることを目的にしたらどうですか
貪瞋痴の奴隷で生きるのではなく
制御できる人間になること
一応具体的に言いました
高度な目的 一つ選んでください
すごいかっこいいんです
心の汚れが落ちるような生き方をすること
智慧が現れるような生き方をすること
人格向上を目指して日々成長する人間になることなどなどの目的があります
いくつか提案しました
何を選んでも同じです
このような目的があるとき
やるべきことは目の前に現れます
例えば 心が汚れないような人間になりますと思ったら
これは毎日の仕事でしょう
人が喋ると怒らないように
興奮しないようにと自分をコントロールする
いつでも仕事はあります
買い物をする時でも 心が汚れないようにと
そうすると必要なものしか買いませんということになるでしょう
あ これは可愛い じゃあ買いましょう
ではないんです 可愛いからと買わないんだと
それは欲であると いうふうに
毎日現在に集中して生きる
何か高度な目的を作ったら
自動的に人間が成長して行動向上していきます
それはやり遂げるものです
やり遂げられるものです
こういう目的があれば
やることは見える 例えば
仏教は宗教として あんた瞑想して解脱に達しなさいと言ったりするでしょ
あれはまずいんです できるわけでもないんです
だから こういうやり方で解脱に達します
毎日毎日 毎秒毎秒何かやることがあるんです
何か宿題があって やる気も失わないし
日々向上していくし 振り返ってみたら相当進んで解脱の扉のそばにいるかもしれません
そこで叩けば開けるということになるんです
やり遂げられるものです
充実感が現れます たとえ一日だけでも怒らないでいたら
吾輩は頑張ったぞという気持ちになりますよ
あの充実感はものすごく必要なんです
もう一つ 仏教はこのあるポイントを言いたいんですね
八正道を歩むならば 精神的な社会的な
問題は何一つも起こりません
今までの説明がわからないんだったら
八正道を暗記してやってみてください
完璧な道です やる気なんか問題にならないんです
八正道は簡単ですけど
八正道の6番目 サンマーワーヤーモ
正精進と言います それはやる気の問題なんです
それでもやる気 やる気って
お釈迦様は具体的に語られるんです
実際する悪をなくす 犯してない悪を犯さない
実際する善を完成する
実際しない善を行うとは
正精進です 4項目です
自分が今やっている悪いことがあったらね
やめましょう 頑張らないとできないでしょ
やめますと決めたらできます
今までやったことがないことはこれからもやりませんと決めるだけ
今までやってきた良いことを完成する
もっとやって それからやったことない善行こと善行為にも挑戦する
それは正精進というんです
それがあれば 意欲は問題にならないんです
目的があって意欲を育てる方法です
はい これで目的がある
意欲を育てる 八正道で
あるいは正精進で 何一つも空から降ってくれません
祈って祈祷してもらって願望が叶うとは迷信です
すべて自力で努力して得る達するものです
嘘じゃないんです 神社のお話したでしょ
神様を教えたっても こちらでやってあげないと神様はくれません
何一つも 心を清らかにすることも
成長することも 何をやるべきかと発見することも
意欲を引き起こして目的に達するまで決めたことを実行することも
全て個人の努力の結果です
そういうわけで 仏教は宗教ではありません
あんた頑張ったら幸せになってくださいと
あんた幸せになったのは私のおかげですではないんです
神様の恵みに預かりましてというのはありえません
そう言われると私は怒るんです
なんでお前だけやと 神って悪人かと
恵んであげるなら すべての生命を恵んでくださいと
はい これで終了やと思います
結論 欲希望があると意欲が起こるが
失敗したら落ち込みが激しくなります
欲と希望があったらね
意欲が起きますよ でも大体失敗するに決まってるんですね
そうすると激しく落ち込んじゃいますね
喜びと充実感を感じるように生きていることです
だから毎日喜びを感じて
充実感を感じて生きてみる
自己嫌悪に陥らないように
自分の良心が自分を責めないように生きることです
自分の人生は他人と自己の役に立つならば
人は常に意欲を試す 自分の生き方は人の役に立つ
自分の役にも立つ そういう生き方をしてほしい
そうすると やるべきことがわからないということが消えちゃいます
何をするべきかとわかる
それで話は終了です はい
どうもありがとうございます
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に来拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーテワジャンツーサッバローゴーウィナッサトゥマーテーバワトアンタラーヨースキーディーガーユコーバワーバワトゥサッバマンガランラッカントサッバデー
ヴァータサッバブッダヌーバヴェーナサッバダンマヌーバヴェーナサッバサンガーヌーバヴェーナサダー スッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリッシュニッチャンワ
ッダパチャイノーチャッタローダンマーワッダンティアユアンノーสุขンバランアーユラアーロギサンプッティサッガサンプッティメヴェジャトニーバーナサンプッティミナテーサミッジャトゥ
はい ウェーサーカマッスルにも参加してください
いろいろブッダの瞑想法とかね
紹介したいと思います
ただ お釈迦様と一緒に1日過ごすだけで
厳しい講演説法とかはありません
ありがとうございます
はい